buonasera l'argomento che mi è stato
dato è molto difficile memoria e
genetica per cui partirò da lontano
partirò da questa immagine che è stata
scattata l'anno scorso quando ha
partecipato alla spedizione in tanzania
organizzata da michele menegon del museo
delle scienze di trento che mi ha
chiesto di accompagnarlo a caccia di
rane e mi ha chiesto di provare a
sequenze a delle rane direttamente nei
luoghi dove lui le cacciava di notte per
verificare se questa specie che lui
aveva trovato era una nuova specie
occorrerà una specie che era già
conosciuta per me è stata un'esperienza
formidabile sia dal punto di vista
personale sia dal punto di vista
professionale ho imparato tantissime
cose ho imparato delle rane anno 50
milioni di anni la storia della mostra
pensa una storia di poco più di 70 80
mila anni al confronto
michele mian che sfigato come fanno le
rane a moltiplicarsi utilizzano un
sistema di richiamo come al solito il
maschio che deve chiamare la femmina e
immaginate questa scena dove avete le
femmine che ascoltano i vari marchi che
cantano questa questa questo canzone che
poi è basata solo su questo gracidare e
le femmine ascoltando questo gracidio
cercano di capire se il maschio marche
vigoroso e più o meno quali sono le sue
dimensioni perché è più il tono al
profondo più questo affibbia grande e
quindi immaginatevi la scena in cui ci
sono le femmine che ascoltano i maschi
maschi naturalmente sono in competizione
fra di loro per procacciare diciamo per
avere la femmina allora primo maschio
comincia a fare crack
il secondo maschio fa e terzo maschio fa
cra cra il quarto maschio cra cra cra e
così via così via considerate questo
fenomeno che spinto dal testosterone per
cui c'è una spinto harmon al e che porta
ai maschi a cantare quindi questa
serenata amorosa quindi pensate quando
ha sentito una rana a cantare per
diverse ore che livello di ormoni ha
raggiunto un livello di ormoni che sale
continuamente fino a quando questa rana
non riesce appunto ad accoppiarsi e
quest'anno sono tornato in un'altra
foresta tropicale che una foresta del
borneo dove c'è la rana delle cascate
siamo andati a caccia della rana delle
cascate che è una rana che ha provato a
chiamare la femmina malafemmina non
poteva sentire perché rumore dell'acqua
copre quello che arriviamo del maschio
allora per saranno ha sviluppato un
sistema un tipo di richiamo che non è
più un richiamo vocale è un richiamo
visuale muove le zampe in questo modo in
questo modo la femmina a in grado di
vedere il maschio
naturalmente anche questo movimento è un
movimento che è dettato da una spinta
ormonale per cui dopo qualche ora che
questa femmine questo maschio chiama la
femmina già tanta arriva a fare una cosa
come questa che per me è una roba
davvero incredibile è una cosa
meravigliosa che madre natura ha
sviluppato ora però come l'ha sviluppata
come fa questa rana ad avere questa
memoria che la porta a cambiare il suo
comportamento perché in quell'ambiente
il suono non può essere percepito il
secondo la marca che è un diciamo è
stata la prima persona che ha pensato
che in fondo al mondo forse non ci era
stato dato non si era fatto consegnato
così come lo conosciamo oggi ha
introdotto il concetto di evoluzione ha
però la marcia sviluppato una teoria
particolare basata sul sul l'utilizzo
nell'organo porta al suo sviluppo
con questo esempio molto particolare che
l'esempio del di quest'animale che
dovrebbe allungare il collo per cercare
di prendere le foglie dall'albero e così
facendo trasferisce all'interno del
collo un fluido che viene poi trasferito
alla progenie per cui figli di queste
giraffa avranno il collo sempre più
lungo ma sulla base di questa teoria se
un giorno la giraffa smettesse di
alimentarsi di foglie dell'albero
decidesse di alimentarsi di foglie che
vivono a terra questo collo col tempo
regredirebbe perché non ci sarebbe più
ragione di avere un collo che continua
ad allungarsi in questo modo ora questa
teoria è stata confutata da un signore
che per 22 generazione ha tagliato da
toro la coda un topo quindi generazione
dopo generazione la coda veniva tagliata
ma la 23esima generazione questo topo
ancora aveva la coda lunga perché questa
era una teoria che non aveva basi
scientifiche
oggi sappiamo che
grazie a darwin che già fatto capire che
l'evoluzione funzionava in quel modo ma
di fatto era dovuta caratteristiche che
venivano trasferite alla progenie che
facevano parte di una diversità che c'è
all'interno della specie oggi sappiamo
che queste caratteristiche fanno scritte
nel dna che il nostro manuale
dell'istruzione nell'uomo abbiamo circa
20.000 istruzioni e le nostre cellule le
leggono tutte per riuscire a costruire
quello che noi siamo e quindi possiamo
dire che il nostro dna in un certo senso
porta la memoria del nostro processo
evolutivo da quando abbiamo cominciato a
camminare ea percorrere quelle strade
che ci hanno portato a colonizzare
l'intero pianeta
quindi se da una parte abbiamo una
memoria all'interno del nostro dna che
fa sì che noi siamo risultato di un
processo evolutivo estremamente
complesso nelle cellule c'è un altro
tipo di memoria che oggi va tanto di
moda un concetto di cui probabilmente
tutti voi avete sentito parlare che è
quello dell epigenetica come vedete
questa diapositiva l'epigenetica e
questa memoria cellulare ereditabile
che modifica l'espressione dei geni
senza cambiare la sequenza del dna uno
dei meccanismi attraverso cui
l'epigenetica si manifesta e la
metilazione del dna è un po come se ne
prendessimo un pennarello indelebile
andassimo a cancellare le istruzioni che
stanno scritte nel nostro manuale sul
libro l'istruzione ancora presente però
di fatto non è più utilizzabile perché è
stata mascherata
ora questo concetto un concetto
estremamente importante e che ci
permette di capire come facciamo ad
esistere tutti gli organismi
multicellulari in tutte le loro cellule
hanno lo stesso dna ci avete mai pensato
noi siamo composti da circa 100 mila
miliardi di cellule che hanno tutte le
stesse istruzioni
eppure se guardiamo al nostro corpo
vediamo che abbiamo cellule che sono
estremamente diverse fra di loro provate
a pensare una cellula del fegato e
confrontatela con una cellula della
pelle sono diverse
ma non lo stesso manuale delle
istruzioni ora come funziona addirittura
tipi di cellule vedete sono circa sono
oltre 200
come funziona al momento del
concepimento
quando quindi la velocità viene
fecondato che si formano zygote noi
passiamo attraverso un processo in cui
le cellule sono staminali totipotenti
quindi sono dei bambini che sono in
grado di fare qualsiasi cosa quando
diventeranno grandi poi però quando la
plasticità si insedia nell'utero
comincia un processo di specializzazione
delle cellule che meno di due mesi porta
la formazione dell'embrione
ecco un po come il nostro percorso di
vita noi quando nasciamo abbiamo la
possibilità di diventare qualsiasi cosa
poi però giorno dopo giorno facciamo
delle scelte ci specializziamo ci
chiudiamo delle porte alle spalle che
impediscono per esempio adesso al 53
anni di fare il pilota di elicottero al
massimo potrà cambiare lavoro e fare il
giardiniere perché una cosa che posso
tutto sommato cercare di fare per le
nostre cellule esattamente la stessa
cosa
inizialmente staminali devono essere in
grado di differenziarsi specializzarsi
poi però col progredire della
specializzazione devono pure loro
chiudere alcune porte e lo fanno me
tirando dna anche utilizzando altri
meccanismi che sono però permanenti che
fanno sì che queste cellule una volta
differenziate mantengono questa memoria
relativa all'identità cellulare che
garantisce che una cellula della pelle
dividendo si faccia un'altra cellula
della pelle questo è un meccanismo
estremamente articolato ed estremamente
preciso è un meccanismo che noi
cerchiamo di contrastare quando
cerchiamo di ottenere cellule staminali
adulte
ma voi sapete la difficoltà che noi
ricercatore abbiamo né produrre cellule
staminali adulte proprio perché
cerchiamo di contraffare un meccanismo
che estremamente efficiente ed efficace
che invece cerca di mantenere questa
identità cellulare ora molto spesso
questi concetti metilazione ereditarietà
ereditabilità sono stati utilizzati in
modo diciamo improprio e questo è dovuto
al fatto che
la metilazione del dna può essere vista
come un meccanismo epigenetico il
pennarello indelebile ma la metilazione
del dna così come tanti altri meccanismi
dinamici che regolano l'espressione dei
geni fa parte anche della vita di tutti
i giorni di una cellula ma non viene
trasferita le cellule figlie
per esempio quando noi mangiamo una mela
quello che facciamo è spegnere tutti gli
enzimi che non ci servono ad accendere i
geni che invece chi servono a
metabolizzare fruttosio quando vediamo
il latte teniamo spenti i geni che sono
responsabili del del metabolismo del
fruttosio invece utilizziamo per esempio
quei geni quindi accendiamo che ci
servono per metabolizzare il lattosio
ora questo meccanismo di accensione e
spegnimento fa parte della vita di tutti
i giorni di una cellula passa anche
attraverso la metilazione del dna ma non
è una mitigazione stabile come se non vi
cancellassimo l'istruzione per un attimo
con una matita e poi usa si con una
gomma per ripristinare l'istruzione ok
quindi il meccanismo possiamo dire
funziona più o meno nello stesso modo ma
le conseguenze sono drammaticamente
diverse questi non sono non sono blocchi
che vengono trasferiti alle cellule
figlie
e poi c'è un altro concetto importante
che viene molto spesso e di cui vi
accennavo prima mani ferme retato che è
quello dell'eredità bilità ora questa
diapositiva alle mie spalle a riporta un
po di titoli che ho recuperato da
internet in questi giorni se voi cercate
su google ed epigenetica e metilazione
troverete 50.000 record almeno che vi
riportano un concetto che così come
quello degli ogm che è entrato nel
nostro pensare comune è sbagliato anche
questo concetto un concetto che viene
interpretato in modo in corretto se
vedete si mescola concetto di
metilazione che quindi questa cosa che
può da una parte portare alle pin
genetica quando viene trasferita alle
cellule figlie con il concetto di
metilazione invece estremamente dinamica
che è quella che
con la quale noi ci troviamo a che fare
tutti i giorni ogni volta che cambia una
condizione ambientale off ci alimentiamo
con qualcosa diverso e addirittura viene
trasferito questo concetto di
ereditabilità alla generazione
successiva come se noi avessimo la forza
di cambiare quello che è il nostro
patrimonio genetico così da trasferire
una cosa diversa i nostri figli come vi
dicevo prima questa è una cosa che non
può avvenire nel momento in cui losi
goti si forma sia un race è totale
perché bisogna ritornare allo stato zero
per permettere alle cellule di poter
differenziare
questo è un concetto che viene molto
spesso man interpretato forse anche
perché siamo essere umani
noi pensiamo che la marca in fondo
avesse detto una cosa molto interessante
ne possiamo sforzarci di cambiare e
possiamo riuscire a modificare noi
stessi addirittura i nostri figli quando
abbiamo sequenziato il genoma umano ci
siamo resi conto invece che molto di
quello che siamo
molto di quello che facciamo invece sta
scritto all'interno del nostro
patrimonio genetico noi però abbiamo la
speranza di non essere solo una somma di
geni che quindi svolgono una funzione
come una macchina abbiamo la speranza
che con l'alimentazione con il respiro
cambiando le condizioni ambientali siamo
in grado in qualche maniera di alterare
i geni se riusciamo a farlo come
riusciamo a farlo sempre anche con
l'alimentazione ma questo non è un
processo che poi alla fine determina un
trasferimento di caratteristiche alla
progenie insomma come chiudere possiamo
dire che speriamo ancora una volta di
riuscire a intervenire cambiando il
nostro futuro ma signori miei
la marca non aveva ragione in alcuni
casi sono riportate eccezioni
letteratura che ancora non riusciamo a
spiegare dal punto di vista scientifico
ma le eccezioni non fanno la regola la
conferma la grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]